à l'ombre d'une aide filao le lycée
louis payen de saint paul est dissimulée
derrière de hautes grilles une
forteresse à travers laquelle on
découvre une oeuvre architecturale
moderne en forme de sextant est ce un
clin d'oeil à louis payen les bailleurs
c'est un homme positif à l'encontre de
l'île non c'était un des premiers
habitants de saint paul à une polémique
parce que c'est une vérité ce gavage et
je sais pas c'était la même époque que
madame desbassyns on sait peu de choses
de louis payen et encore moins de l'ami
avec qui il débarqua à l'île bourbon en
novembre 1663 originaire de vitry le
françois c'est de madagascar que ce
bourlingueur décide un jour de partir
pour l'île paradisiaque abandonné depuis
seize 158 louis payen son amie et une
dizaine de malgaches sept hommes et
trois femmes embarquent à bord du saint
charles commandée par le capitaine
kercadiou payen est ainsi le premier
résidents volontaires de l'île bourbon
mais il n'en est pas de même de leurs
serviteurs malgache
trois femmes pour neuf hommes le conflit
est inévitable
à peine débarqué sur l'île les malgaches
tente d'assassiner les deux français
puis s'enfuit dans la montagne avec les
femmes les deux hommes s'installent près
de la côte au lieu-dit la grotte des
premiers français et baptiste une case
ainsi que des emplois pour les cochons
et les cabris il plante tabac et grains
caire gadio de retour dans l'île deux
ans plus tard découvre cette amorce de
vie économique
il parvient à faire redescendre des
montagnes les malgaches et leur enfance
les premiers réunionnais de souche les
pour louis payen le coeur n'y est plus
le 16 février 1666 il cède aux ordres du
roi la souveraineté du pays contre une
juste rétribution
puis il s'embarque à bord de la vierge
du bon port pour rentrer en france où il
finira ses jours en ermite
you